love Simon is based off of becky
albertalli book and stars Nick Robinson
as Simon spear a young man in high
school who has one secrets he has a
happy life he has nice friends a family
that cares about him a sister who's
really interested in cooking and cooks a
lot of terrible food for him and his
family a mother and father played by
Jennifer Garner and Josh Duhamel who
care for him quite a bit but Simon is
understandably concerned that if he
tells his secret to his family that his
life will never quite be the same and
that secret is that he's gay he's never
come out about it he's never told anyone
about it but he's known for a while now
and when he develops an online
relationship with someone who's also gay
but hasn't come out yet this gives Simon
the courage to do a lot of things he was
always afraid to do so I heard a lot
about this movie going into it a lot of
people asked me if I was going to review
it people were excited to know my
opinion of it I didn't watch a single
trailer and I hadn't read the book so I
had no idea what this movie was about
literally none I went to the film just
completely blind and when it opens with
him talking about his secret I was like
okay I had no idea was about this is
cool I haven't seen it film like this
and that's one of my biggest praises for
love Simon this is a mainstream teen
romance told from the perspective of a
gay man that's very uncommon it's not
something we get a lot and it's not the
only reason this movie is good it's not
just a praiseworthy film because a big
studio is making a film like this it's
extremely well written very well acted
very well directed and it's just a blast
Nick Robinson gives the best performance
I've ever seen from him he's painfully
real but he's not over the top in the
sense where you feel like he's begging
for sympathy this is also a major plus
of this movie it's not looking at
Simon's character and asking us to feel
sorry for him it's just asking us to
relate to him we're not supposed to look
at him and go oh you know it's that's
that's sad he has this situation he's
dealing with in life and he doesn't know
what to do about it that's not the type
of movie that filmmakers have made and
I'm so grateful for that because that
would have just been cringe worthy just
relate to him because you've probably
been through a experience where you are
afraid to tell someone the truth about
something and you're afraid
it's going to up heave your whole life
and that's something I adored about this
movie it's so easy to relate to Simon in
his predicament if you've ever had any
struggles in school of any kind people
you wanted to like or maybe you did like
but you just didn't have the courage to
express yourself or maybe you were
constantly bullied in school there is
something for everybody to appreciate in
this movie and it's not just a
mainstream teen romance
it's actually extremely well written it
feels very authentic something that a
lot of teen romances fall into is that
need for every other scene to be a big
dramatic moment something that our
audiences can appreciate because young
audiences are gonna check out unless
they're talking about Facebook or
Twitter every two seconds that's what a
lot of teen romances do nowadays and
it's always awful this film takes its
time I was about half an hour through
the movie when I realized that it was
just a lot of conversations between
friends and family there wasn't some big
reveal some glorious moments of awe it
was just people sitting down talking
about how they felt and that was really
refreshing and the dialogue didn't feel
forced it was charming witty extremely
relatable every single character had
something about them that you could sort
of understand and appreciate except for
one character which we'll get to in a
second if you've ever been in a
situation even remotely similar to
Simon's in this film you're going to
relate to him in some way especially
with the online relationship because
that's the heart of this movie he has
friends at school and he's trying to
figure out which one of them it is and
so there's all these great scenes where
he's sort of like subtly investigating
like is it is it this guy oh no it's not
him okay it actually provides a little
bit of mystery to the film which I
didn't expect at all I have put a few
small issues with the movie and one of
them I guess is the film's antagonist
it's a kid at school who does some
really awful things and and the film
sort of throws it away as like yeah
that's bad but one stern talking-to and
it's all good after that no this kid
this kid is possibly traumatizing our
lead character and his friends and it's
just it didn't get the right amount of
attention there should have been more
attention to how
dangerous his actions were also in the
opening montage
Simon Says my life is just like yours
except for my one big secret and you see
his life and they have like this bangin
rich ass house and I'm like I don't know
if if your life is like everybody's I
mean my house live nothing like that
When I was your age buddy so I mean I
guess that one little line was just sort
of out of place to me but that and the
film's antagonist in the way the writers
dealt with what he was doing on my only
two issues with the movie I think this
is an extremely relatable and charming
film with amazing performances I'm gonna
give love Simon and a - guys thank you
so much as always for watching look
forward to more reviews very soon I'm
gonna see a wrinkle and time and
strangers pray at night this weekend
you're the best as always thank you very
much and if you liked this you can click
right here and get stuck mine eyes
[Music]